what you what did you do on only fans I
took cute pictures of her feet I did
that as well okay so you so you were but
you're still selling sex you might you
might not have taken off your clothes
but they're not they're not looking at
the only fans to be your friend well
they're looking for something exclusive
that's what only fans is for is support
exclusive content so if I don't post on
my Instagram or my Facebook pictures and
swimsuits cute short dresses or whatever
that is still selling sex but it's from
a different perspective well yeah but
I'm saying you're still selling Beauty
and I'm saying if so smart why don't we
sell brains you can do that